attendu par tous mercredi soir le feu
d'artifice a émerveillé l'aiguillant
courtoi rassemblé près du lac de
Villarois un spectacle en musique pour
ravir les foules qui a commencé plutôt
dans la soirée avec des animations des
stands de restaurateurs associatif mais
aussi un concert pour cette année on
s'est principalement concentré sur les
jeunes on sait que Guan courour a une
population très jeune et familiale du
coup le concert rassemble des reprises
qui sont plutôt modernes avec des
artistes d'aujourd'hui à l'image des
chansons reprises par le groupe parisien
Talès une soirée sous le signe du
rassemblement et du partage
[Musique]
intergénérationnel avec un contexte
actuel difficile en France la fête
nationale prend un sens particulier pour
chacun c'est un des rares moments où on
peut fêter le nom de notre société
donc c temps difficile c'est plutôt
intéressant ça fait du bienUt dire très
attaché donc aux fêtes en général et
d'autant plus à cette
fête qui représente donc la fête de la
patrie je suis très attachée donc à la
France parce que c'est un pays qui a su
beaucoup accueillir toutes les
populations pour moi c'est c'est
vraiment un jour vraiment spécial pour
tous les Français mais pour nous nous
commençons à à rentrer dans la culture
française
un moment de fête et de communion
nationale bien loin des événements
tragiques survenus à Nice la nuit du 14
juillet